all right welcome everyone to today's
session we're gonna start today by a
talk by Emmanuel debate from Princeton
University he was going to talk about
Thank You Philippe thank you to the
organizers for inviting me pleasure to
be here so today I'll talk about
something that was a joint work with two
students at Princeton well Colleen is an
honor student he just graduated from the
math department he's gonna be here in
about a month or two is phenomenal if
you're around talk to him and Enrique is
still an undergrad student at Princeton
math applying now to grad school all
right so my original motivation was
understanding adversary robust AI but I
actually realized that this requires
rethinking the Stiga thing but not
actually get back to the stick so here
is the okay so that's the the actual
framework and the motivations so this is
a context which is I guess fairly common
in unsupervised learning so you have a
data set and you try to understand if
there's any structure in the data set or
you want a representation of the data
points that's useful so it's all it's
often easier to measure interactions
among data points like pairwise for
example like or sometimes it's just
given to you like could be friendship in
a social network it could be that you
count the co-occurrences of words in a
corpus of words of documents within a
distance if you do image segmentation
you will look at the similarity between
pixels inside an image that's PPI
networks pertain to pertains
interactions you see if two proteins are
in contact or not once you have this me
tricks of interaction what you often do
what well I view it as a graph or as a
weighted graph and then often what you
want to do is come up with a compression
of that weighted graph by compression
very often what's commonly used is just
a spectral methods some sort of just
look at some dominant eigen values or
all the non-usable eigen values fully
this gives you a useful representation
of the data points a lower dimensional
representation ok what's interesting is
you start from something that is very
abstract there's nothing a collision and
you end up with no clinton i'm bidding
so here are two examples this is the
most relevant one for this talk spectral
clustering so we have an undirected
graph this is the matrix that we built
the operator the the graph laplacian
these diagonal matrix with the degrees
of the nodes and a is the adjacency
matrix of the graph so the motivation is
that quadratic form from the wizard
oppression exactly measure the
variations of your vector x on the edges
of the graph think of an unweighted
graph for now simplify so now in
clustering what you would do is you
would take your top key eigen vectors
this may not you may leave out eigen
values that are significant for this you
just want to find clusters and that
gives you your spectral embedding so you
started with a graph an abstract object
and now you have each point in let's say
the plane if you take the top two
eigenvalues eigenvectors top we can mean
different thing in this context is the
lowest eigenvalues some time will be the
largest but you it's always clear
usually from the context which side you
want to go alright so then then once
you're in the search engine setting you
can run outdoors I'm like k-means or
greedy algorithm to actually find the
clusters and the point is that it's much
easier to solve the prime in this
context than in the original context all
right so that's the sparser scott
motivation now the other example that i
like to think about and use as
motivation is the vector space models
for word embeddings so you're given a
corpus of words that say wikipedia and
you have a distance of five so you look
at for a chunk of phrases of length five
and you count how many times that the
co-occurrence matrix two words are
occurring in
a small window of five okay you do a few
other things that I'll discuss shortly
but the design idea is the following
then you take the top K eigenvectors
this time you take all the you only
leave out negligible eigenvalues because
what you here the motivation is not to
find clusters is to actually find
vectors such that the inner product of
your vectors is roughly the matrix entry
and for that you need to take all the
Frobenius norm all right so this is like
how did this could look in cartoon
representation and and this surprisingly
keeps preserves a lot of semantic
properties this is a cute fact that is
often mentioned if you take the vector
you obtain for the word King you
subtract the vector for the word Queen
you have ten roughly the same vector as
man - woman so that's the the general
motivation you have some interactions
you build a matrix you use some spectral
decomposition and you have been useful
representation except none of these
really work as I described them so let's
see an example if you generate a random
graph like this two groups of size n by
two and is a 10,000 and you put edges
independently with row ETA by n where a
is two by two
inside each clusters and you put edges
with a lesser probability B by an across
the clusters this is 0.06 then if you
just apply the a person that I described
before the the vanilla laplacian spectra
algorithm this is the cluster you obtain
there will be a first cluster and the
second cluster Ruby's outliers and this
has a very thin cut there's only a
single edge there's enough guys to make
this none to normalize it not too much
and this is thinner than the cuts in the
middle that you want to catch okay
so there's a lot of variance to prevent
this kind of scenarios to happen first
you can do pre-processing steps that are
often news you remove things or add
things then you can use a normalization
where you know lies by degrees random
location SDP is in word embeddings it's
even more of a complex procedure first
what you want to do is normalize the
count by the individual counts of the
words then and then you take something
like magic kernel it could be a
logarithm it could be a root of the
value this is what could the PMI alright
so this is a bit of an art you can use
neural nets and what's important even
like PCE which is even more basic if you
don't properly scale and Center things
you will not even most of them obtain
the very useful representation so the
motivation in this talk is how we do we
design these variable operators and for
that we need to understand how do we
measure reliability so we'll need models
establish rigorous benchmarks and then
the goal is to come up with a principled
way to build reliable operators so this
is I should mention here this is a all
work in progress we I pressured myself
to to present this here and hoping how
we would finish the people we're not
there pretty far from it so take it as
everything is under construction okay so
we first need the models and here are
the block models now it's not just the
usual stochastic block models there's
gonna be a more general family of block
models but that will only talk about two
clusters in the in this talk to simplify
things so we always have two random
variable X and G X is going to be the
clusters so it's basically a vector of
dimension n which is just labeled one
for community one or cluster 1 and 2 so
n nodes with only binary labels and this
will be uniformly at random or
equivalently you can think of the are
iid like color dictionaries Ida colored
with one or two now you have a random
graph on these colored vertices that is
drawn conditionally on these colors and
this takes different forms depending on
the model so the first model is the the
one I already described before this
trust stochastic block model and this
depends on just two parameters
b-besides the number of nodes and as I
said you you know you just put edges
independently so that's an erdos-renyi
graph is probably a inside each group
and then you do a bipartite address
running across the two groups which
probably be yes
just to clarify in the previous slide
when you yeah we don't know what it's
gonna be like it could be a Laplace and
it could be a normal Sebastian to the
other thing the question is we have a
graph or and we want to build an
appropriate and operator such that the
impending is gonna give us the plus so
now this is a may be something which has
been less talked about in the past years
at least in the in the in the scope of
stochastic models it's it's essentially
a a Gaussian mixture epsilon
neighborhood graph so what is it you
just have two gaussians isotropic in the
plane we could do higher dimension but
again let's just talk about the plane
here the separation between the two mean
is s that's the first parameter in the
German that's called geometry block
model yes and then you have this
distance T the threshold any points that
is below a collision distance below T
you put an edge okay so these two models
they capture very different things
that's that that's something that people
like because it captures the probability
that is also very common in will network
which is the small word phenomena that
is this has a low diameter and you could
be I could be friends with Phillip
Phillip could be friend with someone
from high school of friends and I mean
not necessarily friend with that person
so it is true that in many cases there's
not a transitivity in in with graphs
this guy but the problem with this that
it overshoots in that direction it
forgets that in fact in many cases there
is also transitivity filipinos another
person here is lucky that I also made so
often you have both kites of nature
decisions going to the other extreme now
everybody here are the transitivity
property if two nodes are close and
close to a third one it's very likely to
be connected so these are two things
that are very different and we'd like to
actually be robust to this stochastic
type of edges like low diameter and lots
of independence and is very
geometric transitive edges and you can
imagine what comes next we define the
hybrid block model that's going to be a
mixture of these two model so there's
different ways to do the mixture one
ways for example you for any pair of
nodes you flip a coin this property H
between 0 and 1 and depending the
outcome you pick an edge from this model
or this model so now you have low
diameter bit tons of triangles and you
would like to have something operators
that do not offer fit to these models
this is true like locally so you can do
lots of nice thing this has lots of
geometry but we don't want to over fit
all right so you here are the figure of
Merit so first we talk about the
agreement of the reconstruction so it's
a number between 0 & 1 alpha so you have
a block model you have the X and the G
you try it you only observe the graph G
you try to reconstruct X so you have an
X hat estimator of X and you see that
these two have an agreement of alpha if
the the number of nodes that the same
color divided by the total number of
nodes and is alpha or more with high
probability so everything is going to be
miss high property was n when n goes to
infinity so what is the agreement
well you just count how many times you
got the correct color but of course if
it's in the black model if you put
everybody instead of blue and red you
flip the colors but you get the perfect
partition this should count as a good as
a perfect reconstruction so we want to
break that symmetry so you also maximize
over SK is just the permutation case to
here that's the number of cluster
actually but he was just you allowed to
relate all the communities and make sure
that you count up to recoloring you want
to counter the agreement that you have
so agreement of 1 is everybody's correct
and we went of 1/2 when you have to
cluster is the lowest you can you can
get so we are assuming the edge of the
parameters actually everything was of I
think everything I'll tell you you can
estimate this ahead of time the part
estimation problem so let us assume that
we resolved that we have the parameters
of the models then we have two commonly
studied problems exact recovery is when
you want to get everybody correctly
label the full
reconstruction and then we have a weak
recovery or detection when you only want
to get again half is what you can get
even with a random guess when you don't
look at the graph if I just flip a coin
for every node I get by the law of large
number of 50% right so I want to beat
that by a constant epsilon that's the so
this is the least demanding recovery
requirements just beating a random guess
that's the most demanding and then when
you are in between those two I will care
about is to maximize the expected
agreement the fraction of nodes in
expectation you correctly label we don't
know what this could be 80% unless this
talk is about these two quantities
that's the the motivation so let's start
so now it's going to be a bit of a story
it's a the unfortunately the new results
come at the end which is always risky
hopefully we'll get there but I wanted
to really tell you how we build these
things out of this story so in the SPM
let's recall what are the interesting
regimes if I put b0 so I never put edges
across the clusters then if you want to
fully recover the clusters labels then
all you need is a graph to be connected
the two clusters to be connected because
if you have an isolated nodes you don't
know what to do with it that already
gives you a probably offer of 1/2 so you
cannot succeed with high probability so
due to errors when you seminal papers we
know that connectivity in a graph of n
by 2 in an error should be raining graph
of n by 2 happens in the logarithmic
degree regime so probability of the edge
is log n by n with a concern that has to
be more than 2 it's 2 and not 1 because
we have n by 2 nodes right so if we want
to solve exactly cover in this model
when we have a B which is positive we at
least need something which is
logarithmic degree and the question is
can we even do it then or not that that
has been sober we recall the results now
for weak recovery takes a few minutes to
to realize that if you don't have a
giant components which is a component of
linear size in n then also there's no
hope to do anything so if your graph has
a bunch of small components of size log
n then it's essentially the same as
taking a random guess you don't have
enough connections to reconstruct and
this happens when you are you can
in a sparser regime where you are
constant by n now you can remove the log
n and the constant again there's a
facial addition has to be more than two
so these are the two regime constant
degree for wick recovery and logarithmic
degree for exact and the two phase
transition in a special case of B zero
and now we want to know deal with this
case where B's is not zero so how do we
get started on this problem I give you
you see a graph from the stochastic
block model you want to reconstruct the
clusters what do you do well a pretty a
natural starting point is to say why
don't we look for the most likely
clusters given the graph that we
observed the maximum a-posteriori
estimator so if you take acts that are
that are balanced they must be balanced
because there are two clusters then the
probability of observing a given
clustering a clustering x given that the
graph is G is going to be proportional
to the size of the cut so I could write
it this takes only three line but if you
think about it it's very intuitive let's
say I'm assuming here that a is more
than B so you connect with higher chance
inside the groups on a cross if I give
you a graph given that the edge property
is higher inside and across the groups
if you come up with the partition which
has the least number of crossing edges
you must be the most likely because the
total number of edges is fixed so you
may as well put less edges in the cut
this is how it scales this is a number
below one so you want to minimize the
cut so this is maximum a posterior
decoding is exactly equivalent to the
mean bisection problem well I kind of
play with the law of large number here
but this is not important whether you're
exactly balanced or not so this is this
quadratic form is what if your exercise
now I put them plus minus one minus one
in the first group plus one in the
second group this object here is going
to be what it's going to be
AIG X I XJ is going to be well if they
are in the same group and there's an
edge that counts as a plus one if
they're in different groups and there's
an edge it counts as a minus one so that
the number of edges inside the group - a
number of edges across the groups
maximizing that minimizes the number of
edges across the group total number of
edges fixed is observed by the graph so
this is exactly mean by section that's
the balance nests and and remember that
we are this is maximizing this global
property that all your nodes are
correctly label so this is optimal for
exact recovery because this minimizes
the property that you fail in the entire
reconstruction so if this fails nothing
else can work but this is not
necessarily the right thing to do for a
weak recovery or for a partial recovery
right we that's a classical one on
statistics if you want to get the
optimal fraction the Bayesian estimate
estimate er is not the same as the
maximum posteriori well if you care
about the exact recovery and you want to
ask when they succeed or not we entered
this a couple of years ago you need the
a and the B to scale as expected with
log n by n and the two constant in front
so now business re0 have to be larger
the gap between the root has to be
larger than with two and this is a phase
transition again so that's that's the
the exact recovery threshold but this is
the the case where you need logarithmic
degrees now we can still use that and
that has been done I think in a vast
portion of work you can still still use
min bisexual I mean maximum a-posteriori
as your target for the partial case you
can say okay what do I do when I even if
I cannot solve exactly Cori why don't I
still use this figure of Merit in the
sparse case maybe it gives me something
which is not too bad so now the spectral
relaxation the the basic one would be as
follows
I simply relax the integral constrain on
the exercise and make it norm one so now
this is an opinion problem you also are
the luckily if you look at the a and you
plug the old one vector to a you catch
the degree of every node and because of
the addition in nature this is
fairly well concentrated so you have an
eigenvector which is close to that so
being orthogonal to that is basically
telling you take the second eigenvector
of the second largest eigenvalue that's
what you would do with the Vanina
spectrometer on the block model take the
adjacency matrix take the second
eigenvector now how would this behave so
if you if you write the expected
identity matrix and I'm gonna just put
my labels to be the first chunkies
community one the second track is
committed to so everybody here an
expectation as an a by n as the property
of putting an edge here is all B by N
and let's call that's the expected
matrix M so the spectrum of M is very
simple the top eigenvalue with a plus B
by 2 corresponds to the OL one
eigenvector the second eigenvalue with a
minus B by 2 and that's when you put a 1
on these guys and a minus one on these
guys
that's the second vector 32nd value and
then you have 0 with multiplicity n
minus 2 because that's a Rank 2 matrix
okay so now if you're very optimistic
you would think okay that's the expected
matrix maybe there's some nice
concentration behind it maybe the true
I just as the matrix is not too far from
it and perhaps the spectrum of a is
going to break this the second value
into multiple ones but it's going to
keep these two or something that tends
that is close to these two for the top
two I can values so that that is
something that takes place but you need
to have at least logarithmic degrees in
fact this has been studied a lot you
need these papers I think they all have
something that is of the order log to
the power 6 and so Polly logs and the
paper of Van who was really going down
to constant times log and you input here
to accept that they were not exactly
studying this partial recovery they were
in fact styling when you can recover
most of these community labels
I just mentioned that's a parentheses
that if you care about this problem of
recovering everybody then in fact this
easy program works all the way down to
the threshold so that's something we
just did a few months ago and it took a
bit of time to understand so the vanilla
spectral methods take the second hand
vector not only works in constant times
log n but works all the way down to the
treasure that was mentioned in the
previous slides and this was surprising
because if you are really close to the
threshold you know that the error
between the true eigenvector and the
expected one can be pretty large so if
you the expecting eigenvector will have
1 over root N and minus 1 over root n
are the two possible values that it
takes the expected eigenvector is this
guy I normalized it to be unit norm and
what happens is that when you are close
to the threshold your true eigenvalues
can be actually a pretty large so the
norm between UK the case component of
the Trion vector and that's just the
component as we're looking at the second
eigenvector this this is the expected
one this can be pretty large it's gonna
be much bigger than one over root n you
would think ok if I round this guy it's
not clear where I'm gonna end up and
what this show is that luckily when the
values are large they are on the right
side so you don't give you too much on
the on the bad side but you can do it on
the right side you can actually get down
to the threshold with value I approach
but remember that we that's not one that
that we're after in this talk we are
about after the sparse case when you
cannot get everybody and you have
constant degree and unfortunately this
is how the spectrum looks like in the
sparse case for this matrix a your to
your ending value that you care about
the second one is hiding in a bunch of
outliers and what is the largest value
can get here it's a of this order and
the how do you see that so these are the
eigenvalues that the high degree nodes
produce now so because in the constant
degree regime you have lots of
fluctuations in the degrees if you apply
a
Square to an indicator function as I put
one on and vertex V the indicator
function on vector and vertex V this is
the same as the two norm of a Eevee when
you apply indicator of a unit vector to
address the matrix of a graph you pick
the the neighbors of the vertex so the
ax to norm is exactly the degree of that
vertex now the degree in the sparse case
are roughly Poisson of constant
expectation you're looking at the
maximal value of n pi so they are weakly
correlated this behaved like it's at
least log n by log log n so that means
that this that tells you that the second
eigenvalue square is this so this is
going to be root of that so it's very
large
and it completely bears the big a that
you care about here is a what it looks
like so this was an rick had to work
hard that's really plot he took the
block model he run the this vanilla
spectral on e and now you see that what
you catch is this is a first cluster
it's a high degree node and this is the
second cluster so if you prune that's
what I'm gonna do mention quickly next
that's a natural thing to try
it's not going to achieve the threshold
for when you can now you have to print
so much that you actually news your your
graph becomes a completely broken apart
and if you prefer partially you don't
get down to the threshold so this is
also notice this is a different issue
than the first one
the first issue is the laplacian is you
cut outliers tails here we cut the other
extreme high degree nodes so we so as a
classical trick use is you trim that
trimming removing hard we nodes that's
something again used in in many cases
they do this also in the word appendix
in matrix completion you would also trim
trim the largest values but this can
remove potential user information
so not something that seems necessary
like the most natural approach another
approach which is common is normalized
the adjacency matrix or there's
different way that are equivalent to
write it you can do it on the laplacian
or directly on a or you can just put the
inverse on one side all these have the
same spectral behavior essentially you
just try to smash down the nodes by the
degrees so you don't are too sensitive
sensitive to these type of operations
but remember that if you do that then
you're back when you know lies by
degrees you're back to the laplacian
picture or something similar now you
don't normalize your cut by the number
of vertices but you normalize by the
volume of the degrees of the vertices
but still the same issue
Persis so again that's the same graph as
before exactly the same if you don't use
a but you know the normalized oppression
then the high degree node is fine now is
smashdown doesn't catch energy but you
cut again another tail alright so that's
the that's the issue
so trimming doesn't quite work normally
my degree doesn't quite work in fact
even if you use the actual true mean
bisection we believe that this will not
solve we can cover in the most optimal
regime so so that we can prove that mean
bisection doesn't always succeed but
it's a bit of a hack if you give if you
take the entire stochastic block model
you put yourself close to the threshold
I didn't tell you what the threshold is
but if you are in a very sparse regime
at close to a threshold then you have a
lot of isolated vertices to an extent
that you can have enough of them that
you can create a bisection and a zero
cut the mean bisection catches desire in
vertices in some regimes when you can
still solve the problem that's a bit of
a hack because you can say ok why don't
we just look at the giant component yet
it does capture bit what what's
happening even if you you look at the
giant component we believe that this is
a picture but we can prove it that you
have your giant and you can actually
pull out all these tails and if you're
close to the threshold for weak recovery
we believe that there's enough steals
that in fact your cut will be
you're mean by section we'll be at the
periphery rather than in the clusters
but that we couldn't prove because the
two are of the same order you have to
look at the constant Jim tried too hard
I don't know if it's sent here did you
try do you know it can you prove that I
know that there's an aristocrat that
mean by section may not work but is
there a proof that it actually fails
close to the KSR threshold in the giant
only because we can prove it for if
you're not enjoying with these papers
give a very nice detailed picture about
the SDP SDP gives a even lesser cut than
the mean by section so if in bassington
fails because it caches such an thin cut
STP will also fail I believe it will
it's a conjecture but we're not sure all
right so now finally we move to the next
chapter which is we've been thinking of
maximum-likelihood the whole time but
remember that this is maybe not the
right target and this is an example why
so what should we do well if you want to
write the get the right fraction of
nodes then we should look at what's
optimal for it which is maximizing the
number of nodes Albuquerque label the
busiest emitter and this is what it does
so you know maybe just remind you so if
you have a you want to maximize the sum
of you get one so I'm assuming that I
there's always something a little bit
annoying to discuss because of the
symmetry you first have to break the
symmetry because remember there was a PI
there was this relabeling of the
communities let's put this another right
let's assume that maybe I give you a
slight perturbation of the block model
with a symmetric size so that we can
always determine the committee's labels
we don't have the symmetry although it's
a bit technical it's not interesting to
discuss how to break the symmetry we
broke the symmetry so now if you want to
take the expectation of that and you
want to maximize this then you try to
maximize this probability so you can you
have to maximize this for every eye you
can condition by G
you still want to maximize this for
every I so now what you want to do is
pick your guy your exit fi is find the
value of this marginal and put the most
likely value and that Bayes optimal
that's what we want to do so now this
this is a classical example which has
seen is very informative between the
difference between ml and B's let's say
that this was your buck model something
you'll never see the simple case like
just this tree so you put edges with
probity a by n inside the group and be
buying a cross this tells you that if
you look at an edge and there is an edge
here then the confidence you have that
they are in the same group is a times a
plus B those two nodes and you think
that they are a different group with a
by a plus B by a Bayes rule right
because you're you're more likely with a
than B to be in the community in the
same group or not that gives you I
picked this number so that we opt in the
conclusion we want so that gives you
when you see an edge you think with
probably three over five that you're in
the same group if I ask you can you real
able those four vertices for with the
maximum likelihood they may have to
maximize the likelihood what would you
do well there's been lots of tools here
that makes this guy to be a to to make
all these edges happy here you have one
that makes these two guys be a one now
this has two ones and a single two you
want to make this edges happy you make
it to one okay
if you do base instead you want to
marginalize over these middle guys if
you just want to get recover the root so
what you would do here is that now you
have to take into account the two
possible values that v1 can take not
just the most likely so here too as a
very high confidence to be in committee
to one has a pretty low confidence it
could be that just some luck made these
two guys being one so this will be more
likely to be one and these two but now
if you look at the confidence and you
aggregate those three
beliefs then this will actually now with
the value that I chose and the number of
nodes this will say okay I should be in
group two not in group 1 so the cut you
would if you look at where you put v-0
before you have a thinner cut as weeks
for maximum likelihood now you have a
thicker cut but this is maybe much more
sensible because this guy is very sure
to be into three that's the outcome
between an MLM base this is what ml
doesn't quite capture and white can
produce things that are sometimes of
this nature so now this was a toy model
how do we actually compute this true
marginal the property of the single
vertex being one or two or just a dummy
given the entire graph so imagine that
you just look at the direct neighbor and
let's make a simplifying assumption
which is that these neighbors if you
forget about the node that you try to
compute the marginal from so remove it
from the graph let's assume that these
neighbors are roughly independent why
could we assume that well if you're an
SVM or tree like models the loops are
pretty down there with high priority
logarithmic depth so that those guys are
roughly in fact independent so I call Qi
this marginal of each of these node here
given that you ignore that one so now it
would be easy to compute if you had
those margin odds we have no idea how to
get them and if you had them it's easy
how to agree get them to get this node
it's again just baseball so this this Q
channel is the gain is the the channel
you get from the property that you have
of being the same group or not when you
have an edge and that's just base your
case to here and that's
computing this guy from the beliefs of
this neighbor direct neighbors so that's
exactly how you start when you do belief
obligation belief progression is
iterating that by saying okay now I want
to get these these nodes marginals so
I'm gonna go to their neighbors and I
can assume that these guys are roughly
independent of course when you when you
tell to V V prime Delta V is marginal
it's going to use now the margin and V
double prime times to test to V prime
but V double Prime has to ignore both V
prime in V and so by the market property
in this case is simply V double prime
should not you should look at the
neighbors here but you shouldn't look at
the same guy again
when you iterate this in other words
when Sasha tells me I'm gonna have to
test a shower I think he is I should not
take into account your last machine
message otherwise we go into this eco
ember echo chamber so that's that's
exact on the tree if you if you do this
iteration to compute the marginal on the
tree its exact if your tree like you
hope this not too far and amazingly on
the SVM this is giving you
we believe it's a contractor with the
right marginals which is pretty amazing
when when you start with a random guess
at the beginning why because the because
the SVM as this tree like local each
tree like so this approximation seems to
actually be not to hurting you it's
actually giving you the right to see if
you graph is low which we like and the
propagation isn't insane yeah there are
result of this kind yeah what okay
there's often variance like in the SVM
for example we don't really do it with
we don't yet have it with a random
initialization what we have is what I'm
going to do next is the linearized
version of VP that we can prove but it
doesn't give you the right marginal but
you can prove it gets you this quick
recovery now some major issue of about
VP is that a those updates rules are
known in our and kind of sometimes a
little bit tricky to to estimate in the
SVM is not too bad but if you are but
they are very dependent on the model to
compute correctly base it's very
important that you know your your
parameters and when you go on a model
with you on with data you have to you
have to learn some values for these
parameters it also doesn't jenna is
necessarily to models like the GBM that
i mentioned it does vary because do you
have tons of loops all the presumption
breakdown and even to write down the
update rule is complex in those model
because they're eden
variables that the geometric locations
so this is something that was proposed
in the context of the block model why
don't we simply linearize belief
obligation meaning approximate those
ugly formulas
close to the uniform guess that you do
at the beginning so i skip the details
here because i want to get to the graph
boring if you work out the linearization
of BP
what you happen is that those recursions
now give you a power iteration on a
linear operator we can write down like
this linear operator is and what because
you don't want to use when you tell that
beliefs you of course don't want to use
that node from here to here this is the
matrix that comes out of it so here's
the done backtracking matrix of the
graph it acts on the number of directed
edges so you look at your graph and you
make it directed put two edges per edge
one in that sense and in the reverse
direction and you put a one between
entry n F of the matrix if F follows so
if you have this continued extension but
you put a zero if the edge loop back or
if the edges are disjoint that's exactly
the capturing what I mentioned before in
the example with Sascha we don't want to
look back in our beliefs so taking a
power iteration on this operator which
corresponds to the second eigenvector is
roughly linearizing the previous
algorithm so this approach was proposed
so the good news is that it actually
solve weak recovery in the most
challenging regime so in two group it
has a nice expression in k group also
I'll skip the details this is optimal
for two groups we can prove only for two
groups because starting from four groups
we have this computational gaps that
take place so they did the the ideas and
heuristics behind the none backtracking
we're first proposed in that paper
that's where they give the name of
spectral Redemption because spectral
used to fail now you have a new operator
that actually works so that so that
would be the answer to your question see
that's not quite a laplacian and and
this was first proven in board anonymous
to be a large for a family of SPMS then
we did for the general case of SB M here
this is really using the spectral method
the analysis of this operator here we we
studied the power iteration the BP like
approach and these are two papers that
obtained that thing we study different
methods earlier the survey that I wrote
that gives a much more detailed
references about this works I'm skipping
a lot that's the right intuition of why
this non backtracking operator works in
the block model remember we said before
if you take a high degree no
you create energy by just when you power
by just going too much around these
nodes when you use the non backtracking
operator because you cannot go back you
force the the operator to push you away
then when you take powers of this non
backtracking operator you leave this
high degree node and if you leave the
high degree node because in the block
model you don't end up in an other high
degree nodes with high probability that
makes the you that you don't longer get
disrupted by these high degree nodes and
now you focus on the communities that's
a rough intuition so how much of a
Redemption is it really so here is the
geometric block model you use the non
backtracking spectral algorithm and this
is the cluster that you obtain what you
pick is a tangle which is a collection
that that's a very dense region which is
denser than the other ones a bunch of
clicks that are all intertwined
this is 2-dimensional and the
explanation is very simple well non
backtracking makes you move away from a
high degree node but in a graph like
this we stand off loops where you if you
have a high degree nodes you go back to
it this dimension it will help you when
it grows but it will happen for any more
dimension if you have a large enough
dimension Proby will be better
all right so spectrally we can probably
prove this as friction NPM fails due to
tangles it's in some regimes what works
in the SVM is the good old normalized
laplacian because in that case I mean it
doesn't always work it still do we still
have cases where it catches a tail but
in that case the random walk seems to
stabilize much more in the two groups
here and nothing for cross as much and
it actually seek that's the that's a
perfect reconstruction of the nodes you
do what will be optimal the two groups
and split them in the middle but
remember that the normalizer passions
fails on the SVM because now it catches
those tails so you can see where I'm
going
the question is how do we curb the
enthusiasm around the tangles like VP
those kind of method the go to Susy a
stick around the tangles without
promoting tails if we smash down those
tangles by their degrees now we got we
may
these other guys that are outliers
become too important alright so this is
the the proposal that we have craft
pairing so what's graph powering so if
this is your graph G give you an example
of powering you simply add an edge
between two vertices that are close
enough in the in the graph distance so a
power of two I just add an edge between
two vertices of a distance 2 in the
graph and you keep the other edges power
3 I had an edge between everybody a
distant 3 so now these two for example
get connected I do not the power I get a
complete graph in this case the
definition graph powering for a graph G
the Arth power of the graph corresponds
to adding an edge between any vertices a
distance at most are less or equal to R
it has a nice and simple way to
represent it in terms of the adjacency
matrix so take a and I'm adding self
loops to the graph so I'm putting 1 and
diagonal instead of zeros so identity
plus a if you used to work with the zero
diagonal now the power the graph has an
adjusting matrix of a parentheses R
which is simply well if you just do
power of this original RZ matrix your
accounting walks of length R unless
between I and J and this would be very
uninteresting operator because you just
the eigenvalues of this guy and the
eigenvectors are what the eigenvalues
are scaled by r it's lambda I to the
power R and the eigenvectors are exactly
the same so you wouldn't do anything by
doing just this so graph powering is
simply thresholding that you take your R
power and then you just look if this is
more than one I put a 1 although I said
put a 0 so you're back to a graph you
start with a graph you get a new graph
that you add evidence you sort of
complete the graph where maybe they
should have been there's enough evidence
they should have been an edge
so rough intuition of why this is doing
something that how we actually got to
that remember that in this example the
mean cut was here but this is not what
we wanted we want to take take
confidence so if you had these extra
edges that were here now you can see
that the main cut is longer here it's
here so you make in fact this guy in the
group
you put your min cut here you make this
guy in book two so in a sense having
those edges is gonna make some cuts that
may be direct cuts that may miss thin
but they're not the right one if you
look at this further evidence that the
further distance release is now notions
of cuts might be again on the right side
but we have to be careful we want to do
this kind of thing so that we don't
count too much two loops so if I were to
just use the power of the matrix which
we know is not a good idea but then this
would tell me that these two vertices
have if I do three powers they have two
paths of length three here two works so
that would tell me there's twice more
confidence in a sense that they are in
the same group now because I use this to
power which we know it's not the right
approach if you do based optimal because
they share an edge so graph power ring
is doing something it's not clear why
the right thing to do is just trash
holding that is saying okay I use
evidence which is deeper but I don't
want to get too much overwhelmed by this
evidence instance I don't want to just
additively it's not clear this could
look like we understood now maybe but
actually you don't understood you still
overshoot that's a surprising thing and
this is how it ended still is imagine
you have a dense graph say take a clique
for example and you had this single
vertex out if you take the cut of this
edge is is very thin but if you take
only one power on this graph then you
absorb that edge right because now every
it's adjacent to everybody in this in
this graph so you completely remove it
so that's very that's a bit vague it's
just intuition but basically powering
does a decent job at getting this deeper
feedback without them define lips too
much and why it absorbs the tails so
before I'll give you a few numerical
results
so that's a the SVM with these
parameters that's close to the case
threshold by the way I keep saying cast
ratio that's this threshold for when we
calorie can be solved so the the the
difference we tried the adjacency matrix
the pressure known as laplacian non
backtracking walks and these powered
adjacency matrix so we do spectral
method but the on the second eigenvector
we pick but on the powers graph so as
you can see as expected the the purple
is the non backtracking walks he's doing
very well and he succeed all the way
down that essentially the close to the
threshold this is the diamond and the
number of vertices growing now if you
look at this method the addressee matrix
in the laplacian they do well at the
beginning and this is because the high
degree nodes don't kick in this log n by
log log n is too small and the good
eigenvalues are still the one that you
like so they do pretty well when you go
to lower dimension that are pretty large
10 to the three 10 to the 4 and then
they crash down eventually but when you
power the graph then you stay and you
fold in on backtracking walk now that's
on the geometric block model here you
can see that the the good the normalized
a passion does pretty well is the random
walk cache is the cluster pretty well as
expected non backtracking walks as
brutally in all these ones no
backtracking la pasión and also the
attorney they get this type of lawyers
that i described before empowering does
fairly well this is powering here it's
between two and seven here it's been 2
and 25 we can see that I will have to
discuss a bit wait a minutes how many
powers can you take we'll have to talk
about it and that's I now in the hybrid
block model now I have both lots of
tangles but also low diameter meters the
mixture model I took the same models as
in the previous slide but mix them is
fairly half as you can see a power
operation the power graph does pretty
well spectral the second one that does a
fairly well is normalized a fashion the
other one did on the way
okay so now the spectral resurrection
it's after the redemption so the exist
are and you would take our to be epsilon
for example times the diameter that
works it has to be large enough it could
be smaller but if you want a jarek
result that works for all the models you
would take some arbitrary small there is
some small epsilon positive for which if
you multiply the diameter and you power
that match then you solve with curvy on
both model SVM and GBM and also we
believe that you get exact the optimal
fraction of note in the GBM you get the
optimal fraction on the SVM you need to
use the model parameters so these
spectral methods will not get there you
have to run V P eventually so now that's
the that's the the picture that you have
to kind of remember from this talk if
there's any one you should remember this
is remember that's the ugly spectrum in
the constant degree regime of gyro lot
that's for just in the SVM the guy that
you look for is hiding in those high
degree nodes and tangles if I do a to
the power just algebraic power we know
that everything is gonna scale to the
power R but this guy stays in the middle
nothing new happens if you take the
graph powering what happens is those two
guys scale faster so everything scales
but the informative eigenvalues the
scale faster and they'll stick out in
so for the SBM as the paper the first
paper of Massoud II that proves how to
get to care special uses something which
is not too far it's counting passes of a
given X between two vertices that I
think it's important to discuss the
differences
let's call a square parentheses are
between I and J this would be the number
of our self avoiding walk so path
between ing an arch taking logarithmic
in the paper whereas here what we do is
we first have this a whispering well if
I want to make it look a bit closer to
this operator you can count the number
of less than our path inj then I just
put the trace the indicator function you
know if you count the number of paths of
length R or less is the same as counting
walks so already this is helping with
the complexity because counting paths if
you're not in the block model if in the
block model passes and none but written
walks are about the same so you can do
this efficiently but in another model
counting path is going to be expensive
whereas because you don't look at
exactly R but less than R you can just
count walks that's our first difference
but the most important difference is
this indicator which is very important
because if you use that on the German
trick block model you again have the
prime of tingles you get to you
overshoot with the tingles so the
stretch holding is there is the key in
you ingredient and this is also helping
with the complexity on graph that are
not the SPM the other thing which is
nice is if you care more about the
mathematics of it this goes from a graph
to a graph because you lots of nice
things that also happen I mentioned a
few in the next line
and so what's happened now is that if
you look at a sparse cut in the power
graph this correspond to a sparse a deep
cut in the original graph so so you know
that if you look at the original graph
at the sparse cut you get a bad cut
after this borrowing basically the cuts
that that you look now they're not just
cuts because they look at to this this
works and you can terminate them but
let's see have we said do we get a few
more minutes after no then when we
started when I mean I don't really need
to overdo it's just you want to see a
graph with the difference between a cut
and a deep cut or not an example
yeah okay yeah I mean we can stop here
but if the tree was a bit in completely
done man I didn't put all the edges so
it's pretty simple you you do something
like that
so now the the min-cut here I mean by
section is going to be here you have a
score of two if you power the graph you
add all these edges and here you have
you have to add a lot of edges see now
this guy gets connected to this guy this
guy this guy this guy so now you can see
that if you count the new cut becomes
here that's just an example anyway
that's that's a bit high level but
basically now this is going to catch the
committee's as opposed to this one yes
this gets a DP that's the result that
I'm presenting here yeah so I mean we
don't know yet what there is the paper
is going to look like it's already very
long and we want to keep it short we
don't know what we're gonna pull II
prove or not it's still in there but but
that we know is true yeah that's not
that's a more precise picture of what I
said before if you if you want to know
so what really happens is this if you
take a power which is that large this is
that this is a poem from the news that
creates with the old one vector that's
the the guy that we care about they're
up by a constant then I could
Ramanuja the name Ramanujam like is
because in the if you work with a d
regular graph random the regular graph
you know that you're almost Ramanujan
which means that the spectrum is the the
d eigenvalue here and then there's a to
d minus 1 here now you know that if you
take an address when you graph then we
don't have at all this type of
separation so there
but if you actually if you just care
about getting the general behavior of
getting larger of revenues and screws of
per of revenues then you get something
which is similar except that there is to
a regime here in the first this is the
high degree nodes now they are like the
degree to the power R by two plus
something that is only small compared to
this dominant term and then you have
here the bulk which are the if you take
a random vector and you apply to the
paragraph then it would catch the R by 2
plus constants so if you really only
forget about all the O's even those
bigger roles here because this is a
small compared to R then you are
basically Ramanujan like for the
paragraph let's keep the the derivation
of that okay so here is something I've
mattered also for application powering
to the to the constant and the diameter
can be expensive if you graph as a half
a million nodes and you you have to
power fifty times you can see that it's
gonna it's not impossible we've done it
with graph of dimension 300,000 on a
laptop you can do like up to 2030
powering but the the the next the
combination then is as follow if you
really want to take our to be practical
what you can do is combine powering with
normalized the by degrees so you power
first a few times so that you don't make
your normalization be too sensitive to
now sparse region and then you normalize
by degrees so now if you do this powered
laplacian now you can take instead of a
constant time times the diameter you can
take it to poly log and still get the
thresholds I'm putting something on the
right is that we also do some some
regularization before so the few things
I'm a bit hiding but this is
additionally log to the power 3 which is
much better than now here is something
that the very interested is a can we
combine powering and specifying
specifying is the you have a graph it's
maybe dance and you you can remove some
edges put zeros and you change the
weight of other edges in a way that you
preserve the quadratic formula passion
powering is some sort of do Allah
in the other sense you start with a
graph that could be sparse but you add
edges where there's some evidence that
it should be edges and then you
regularize the spectrum now can we
combine those two in a way that we don't
do we add all these edges and then we
remove them all can we power and specify
on the fly that would be good because it
will allow us to not go into this issue
of having to power everything and you'll
also be interesting to see what happens
so if you take a graph another shiny we
know it is far from having a spectral
gap let's say we power it so now we make
it have a nice spectral gap which is
almost up which is roughly optimal then
what happens if we specify that power
graph do we get an expander do we get
something which is sparse and has a
spectral gap that could be maybe a a new
way to construct a graph is good
spectral guys will values I guess will
did us at all drop so some more things
we're working on that's what I said
before pairing to extract special gaps
trying in qinger it seems like in many
instances we even thought maybe in
nearly all but we have come to examples
if you paragraph you can seem to get the
Titan sugar to the lower bound the the
the conductance becomes tied to the
eigenvalue not the screwed of the
eigenvalue that's what I mentioned
before okay in that okay we have a way a
version for weighted graphs but okay I
think yeah
any questions yeah so if I understand
correctly basically you're saying that
graph powering fixes the issues that
we're having the spectral methods does
it also help with issues of who's the
wat'ry okay so you can do min bisection
directly so then you have this perm that
I just series that in some cases on the
SVM you may still cut the periphery and
yes yeah yeah yes yes so we have a
discussion about that so here is
something that I instead of taking the
identity we start okay what if we take
some nonlinear kernel here and for long
I kept in Cohen I I think like this is
maybe too strong to flatten it at one
you should have a smaller so now Colleen
convinced me that this is the other way
around we should actually make this go
down even more than the indicator
function basil if you will if you don't
want to use an order to normalize the
power laplacian if you don't normalize
by degrees most likely the optimal
function is that you're shooting that
goes down because you still the still
tend to overshoot by once you have all
these loops all these tangles you don't
normalize by degrees you just power is
not enough so now there is probably a
business of understanding the perfect
kernel depending on different models and
you can probably derive the right kernel
if you want to maximize the accuracy of
your algorithm but the risk is that
again it's going to be a discussion that
is very much dependent model dependent
and for the Ezard for the GBM or for
whatever you will do something different
and we are we were carrying trying to go
away from having having worked a lot on
the SVM to overfit so we said this just
sounds like something simple and that
that that is doing very well and quite a
few things we tried even real data
I was just gonna ask about the weighted
graphs
I mean Thalia so you just put an
exponential in front and so that does an
actual thing to combine the weights so
if this was a normal graphed is just is
there a pass or not then you have to be
careful because let's say that you
normalize your weights to be all between
zero and once then long pass will count
nothing so you have to be scaled by the
length of the pass and then this is one
possibility it takes the most likely the
the highest signal you get between two
points so that's like the trash holding
effect so that that's a bit eristic we
don't have result about that and and one
thing I'm hoping yes but we are hoping
to anarchy first time in his senior
thesis will try to apply this to the to
the worst embeddings instead of doing
log PMI type of things that's kind of
Dijkstra that's what we think is a
natural extension of that and we'll see
how that so if you don't hear from me it
means it in general of course after you
so in the insert interest of time maybe
we should take the rest of the questions
offline and we'll select thank you menu
come back at 11
let's see